[Music]
in scary obsessed news Oh submitted by
Justin from Santa Anna an armed fan
targeted youtubers in their own home
what we offend hit close to home he
brought a gun to the place to their home
to the face
see that's why I always been saying I
know that's why I never wanted to reveal
my identity I didn't want to show my
address or anything else ready no
because I got a lot of guns now but back
then I didn't that's true that's bad we
got an alarm we got dogs we got guns we
got part we're good technically all you
need is part I think it's pretty good
yeah me I have two kitties I have a
slingshot and I have a nerf though [ __ ]
you up let's [ __ ] my arms up all the
time before you [ __ ] random scratches
oh [ __ ] me easily I'm allergic unless
you get me I got a kazoo and I can drop
my pants really fast yeah so youtubers
uh names are Meghan tourney and Gavin
free this is what they look like they
look like our YouTube people I like a
sweater it's pretty awesome right yeah
you two better get you know that slow-mo
got it oh that's why we don't know what
he looks like she does a Kiwi fastball
girl would have never guessed I'm sure
they don't know what we look like either
yeah so dependent no we are much they're
watching right now like I do oh I love
you guys
oh I guess we do look very white and
we're sweaters
yes there was this crazy obsessed fan so
he was obsessed with Megan but he hated
Gavin whoa
because of the fact that Gavin's Megan's
boyfriend that's what you meant by love
love hey he's not good-looking enough
for her so he wanted to take her away
yeah so this guy who's Christopher he
drove 11 hours from New Mexico all the
way to us too long he's dedicated what a
dedicated fan first two hours done first
to our first [ __ ] thought of like
driving that much look like I really
would like I'm picturing myself as a
crazy person two hours in I'm like you
know not worth it
you're not pictured as opposed to crazy
person and I remember that NASA lady who
wore diapers and [ __ ] went like 14
hours in that car and she tracked down
her ex and like tried to kill him I
think you're a lot of cool stops are in
the in between those places but do you
take selfies in that crazy mindset
if you know it's like time your anger
disappears yeah yeah mine who disappears
in about two hours soon I'll be [ __ ]
pissed and I like two hours Wow I like
how Jodi fought with all the tourist
traps he's like I'm gonna go kill this
person but oh [ __ ] meteor craters in 87
miles I do I try to stop at every single
one so and me and Jess was rubber
tripping there is this sign called the
thing there's like all deeply bell
billboards the thing the thing the thing
and I'm like we're gonna go see the
thing yeah and they're like Here Come
more idiots to see the thing as they see
you coming off the road it was like a
huge gift shop with like a little Museum
of old collecting things and then the
thing was just a fake wrapped up mummy
[Laughter]
tell me how much it was like two bucks
or so I thought it was awesome but just
got scared just got scared of the nose
it was really dark and then in the
middle was like a trailer park and there
was no one there I was a rapier so yeah
it was it looked like a zombie movie so
then at the very end they're like noise
and smell let's you saw the truth but
you still committed gonna like yep
and it was like oh it was like old cars
and like bills a Bonnie and Clyde car
with like blood and people dead and like
like gunshots all over she's like I
don't know honey
I don't know honey he's like we're here
to see the thing all right like thriller
like she's like I don't like it oh you
were the big man hell yeah oh you're
really funny if you just kicked her out
and lock the door just went off okay
that's not you have a girlfriend I don't
know yeah I've done some pretty dumb
stuff gonna be in contest anymore
I love tourist traps I've learned yeah
so back to this here so they this is
Christopher by the way
yes Lucifer oh yeah he looks like that
sure looks like he could be my brother
[Laughter]
you guys grow the same facial hair the
content of yours or something good very
well could be yeah so so the couple
woken up at 3:40 a.m. because they heard
some glass shatters oh [ __ ] jinx it yeah
and then so they ended up hiding in
their closet and while they were hiding
in the club both of them yeah so you
hear glass like logging in there wait
turn our night-vision protocol when that
happens what when somebody breaks it you
have a house protocol right oh yeah for
me I grab the gun I run to her I hear
the noise all right that's the first act
quickly and act violently that's what
it's like your dad kill it's cute yeah I
know what if it's someone missing
accidentally while you pull the trigger
last you assess a situation but I act
first act quickly and I act violently as
fast as I can
he always grabs the gun everybody here
to the threat that's it I'm there like a
second what if the seconds not fast
enough then I'm I'm sorry I'm faster
than a second dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
I just said my dog's bail the dopest
karate chop I've ever seen it started
here and ended here draw your drawing or
a bow what I have pills you'll see yeah
they were hiding in the closet they were
calling that on one and they could hear
him searching for the couples oh and
surveillance must be scary though he was
he was walking through the home with the
gun in his hand ready to kill Jesus I
know
Vogons Gary so then luckily the cops so
apparently he decided to leave so he
ended up going into a driveway he was
about to take office and that's when the
Austin police arrived and they ordered
him to stop either the cop shot or he
shot himself he died Christopher died in
this is one of those times when I feel
like good job cops you go yeah I gotta
kill him because they you know he's
dangerous
he would drive 11 hours not even stop at
any of the tourist traps you didn't see
it being crazy yeah that's a lot of
discipline that's crazy
and then they also found searches of his
cell phone and stuff that there were
various notations identifying both Megan
and Gavin by name and further
threatening thoughts were recorded by
Christopher and directed towards galv
Gavin saying things like I want Gavin
free to die alone with no children the
father who went there - no woman is ever
worth that trouble trust me they're more
trouble than they are freedoms okay
these guys don't know that's cuz they
never been in a relationship so they
don't know what a real relationship is
like so all they just watch all these
movies and then they go like one day I'm
gonna love her like nobody else come on
girl dude they never know what a [ __ ]
show everything is behind the scenes
I've known so many YouTube was over the
years dude and every time I see these
the the perfect image of the perfect
couple at all prettied usually worse
it's the worst [ __ ] ever always yeah
always the most [ __ ] nightmarish
[ __ ] hellscape like behind the scenes
but people don't know that they just see
like the [ __ ] perfect edit cuz it
you're not gonna leave your argument in
the video like mocha like [ __ ] out what
I would do but the
we went on a tour with some youtubers in
Australia and some of the ones with the
most Disney image are [ __ ] coke cos
you're asking for coke every venue and
we're like what the [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
and they would tell us they were like
hey the promoters are ever like hey you
guys have to turn it down
are you guys a [ __ ] edge I know what
you guys gonna do on stage to any of
that we're not going to we knows the
church of course I'm not gonna [ __ ]
say crazy [ __ ] right party but see then
you come off like like you know crazy or
whatever yeah the people who follow you
but but then these people are supposed
to be more perfect than you but there's
a [ __ ] show so [ __ ] coke all day I
did a show with [ __ ] what's-her-name
she's fine she's big now but she wasn't
then bebe Rexha she's like this huge
artist right so literally they sit me
down and they go hey just let you know
there's kids out in the crowd do not
curse and just be very mindful and it'll
give me a serious talk also yeah I told
you like I'm a professional I don't have
to curse yeah cool walk out Bibi goes in
front of me she goes [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
I'm sorry I'm not supposed to [ __ ]
curse play anyways dude she Karl went
down like I look I like Shay personally
like oh no I'm a long time but like I
wasn't crazy surprised because I've like
like I remember would win the videos
like when he's doing his videos and
stuff like he has this image thing but
then we all knew that shade drank and
like smoke didn't did stuff like so so
hearing this wasn't like the nuttiest
[ __ ] in the world yeah like like Mormon
family guy I'm a dad I don't drink it
was we didn't attach to it so it's even
with religion that he's a Mormon so yeah
so the expectation like the the the the
level that he fell was higher because he
it was built up higher I see because the
the perception for the audience was just
that it uses the perfect dad and all the
[ __ ] yeah you know I mean I think like
to like when you don't you have to out
your laundry before somebody else does
so it's like for example let's say like
an article came up where I robbed the
hostess Factory like what its gonna be
like
well how many was the other time right
yeah they're like wow I hope he gets a
lesser sentence I do expect you to do
this yeah my appetite drug is to be
opposite like I air out all my [ __ ] on
camera and that relaxes me and when I go
home I'm like a chill person most of the
time that's the scary [ __ ] behind your
eyes oh you know what happened poor Jess
hashtag gorgeous you know you know you
know I love just because like she knows
how to calm me down
so we got into a big fight the other day
and went butt-naked
no no she started recording me and I was
like you recorded me right now you're
gonna blackmail me and I was all like oh
my god but it made me love her even more
cuz I'm like man you're so smart like
that would no one would ever know how to
stop me in my tracks when I'm when I'm
getting in my life my fit and I'm like
having my tantrum and I'm yelling you
know can I do with Isaac you started
recording him really when did you stop
him we're saving this for the vault
Isaac you're older you're gonna see what
you because we're obviously we're gonna
be posting that stuff but like this
desert does that work on earth does he
like stop his tracks well we were Japan
he was acting of so much we remember
that trip so much you know just like I
think you're driving me crazy inside
like finally when he's to start having a
tantrum like Casey start rolling start
rolling right now so we're start
recording him as soon as he sees the
camera on you'll be like I would have
literally never given a [ __ ] as a kid I
wouldn't give a [ __ ] as a [ __ ] for an
outlet you can't I would just start
putting more holes in the wall yeah you
want a show nobody's an adult your life
wait up the world's gonna see how stupid
I'm acting like right now it's true so
let me calm down and talk to you like an
adult have you ever noticed that when
you're vlogging in public and stuff that
it's it's almost like you're you're like
CNN with a camera there and people are
coming up in the background
yeah doesn't matter how small the camera
to like it so I could even be doing it
with your phone and people are like what
they do Vegas do not even be here right
this isn't a live feed you idiots like
this [ __ ] international we're at the
Colosseum in Italy and we're trying to
vlog and there's these little [ __ ]
Italian girls jumping back and forth
like this they change when they see a
camera it's like the nuttiest [ __ ] it's
just yes people in the background a
photo bomb
wait yeah what the [ __ ] like just
because it's a camera like everybody
that has a camera now we were doing
everyone's noise listing with his video
mise restaurant and there's just one
dude like just being so [ __ ]
obnoxious I'm just trying to grab a shot
of the front of the store and he said
put the camera on him and he's kind of
far away from me alright continue what
do you want to do he goes I just watch
the outside
alright [ __ ] loser there you go idiot
keep going just continue talking [ __ ] he
just doesn't know this is no [ __ ] up
knocks you say what's gonna happen I'm
gonna put this in here my favorite
social media at taking advantages of a
moment for social media story is during
the recent hurricanes but people were
taking cameras and going outside and
filming it from everybody and then and
then like there would be live chats of
people watching it live because they
were broadcast live from their phones
and then any time to feed cut everyone
would would you know the mean like press
f to pay respects you didn't hardly die
yeah right cuz there's some game where I
guess you press F and you pay respects
to somebody so as soon as the camera
cuts out because it was a crazy [ __ ]
hell storm outside right so soon as the
camera cuts out you see the chat and
just say ffffff like that [ __ ] was
amazing but people were taking advantage
of this moment to try to get like a
little bit of soju - exactly
the hub is so awesome just to see the
camera and you're like how this guy in
the air he died oh and I'll be crazy if
it's in the herkie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]